this morning the man who's dedicated his
life to saving a language and culture
that was almost lost and the complex
he's built that contains a vast treasure
of storytelling aaron lansky runs the
yiddish book center in western
massachusetts over the past 40 plus
years it's gone from an idea that many
dismissed to an institution of higher
learning in and of itself a place
dedicated to preserving the past while
making sure some parts of it
are never repeated
oh my gosh
what do you think
that's a lot so that's it it's a whole
culture sitting here inside a fireproof
climate-controlled basement in western
massachusetts
rest more than a thousand years worth of
stories
if not for aaron lansky much of it might
have been lost forever the places where
many of these books came from you know
were sort of erased from the map that
the stories they tell were about a
civilization that was almost wiped out
[Music]
to understand what lansky has done here
on the campus of hampshire college you
have to go back to the first big waves
of ashkenazi jewish immigrants
arriving in america from europe and
russia at the turn of the 20th century
speaking a language they'd used since at
least the 11th century
initially they embraced their own
culture i mean they were still speaking
yiddish they were i forget six or seven
daily yiddish newspapers in new york
city alone there was yiddish theater was
thriving in new york but by the next
generation that was no longer the case
you know the price of admission in
america was that you uh you couldn't be
too different the united nations swear
to punish germany for its brutality
against the jews assimilation though was
of course not the main reason yiddish
seemingly vanished nazis have even
burned culture before world war ii there
were more than 11 million
yiddish speakers around the world right
there are now how many
we don't know the exact number now maybe
maybe a million uh but what we do know
is that of those 11 million user
speakers fully half of them were
murdered during the holocaust so it
wasn't exactly a natural death people
sometimes forget that
when lansky first began visiting the
homes of many aging jews around the
country to collect material as a
graduate student
he was given an estimate
there were probably about 70 000 yiddish
books that could be tracked down
so i figured all right 70 000 books i
could save that in a year or two you
know and get back to my studies
the only trouble was they were so wildly
off
so we've now saved about a million and a
half volumes
and wow and we're still going strong in
fact we saved more books during the
pandemic than we had in 10 years
previous i just got goosebumps oh that's
good yeah when you talk about how many
books yeah have been saved yes yes
today beyond the fireproof facility in
the basement of the center there's the
main floor a sprawling space that can be
stacked up against the best libraries in
the world
the yiddish book center still goes out
and collects books but many are also
sent
boxes and boxes every day
this is nice actually that's very nice
really unusual that is nice as david
mazzauer and rachelle grossman showed us
a lot of children's material here this
is cute this is my aleph base my
alphabet oh and so you can see it was to
teach the different letters so this is
fae for fed which is a horse
it's like you're opening a someone's
house their life
all of it absolutely and the variety of
books is so interesting so this is a
book about the talmud so somebody who
had
english yiddish learning materials who
had stories who had children's books
also maybe had a strong interest in
religion now this one is really amazing
so i think you actually will recognize
this book
oh wow so this is a more recent book
this is a translation of um
through storage right
george they're niagara george the
curious one yeah so it's done actually
um in transliteration with english
letters and then also in yiddish and
people are using these people raising
their children in yiddish people who've
made a conscious choice to keep the
language alive in their family are using
these books and want more of these books
to to read with their kids dear ma for
sure this is the earliest memory of for
me of a book that you read to me mind
not learning yiddish is perhaps your
biggest disappointment wow you're 85
years young so here's your chance
brilliant isn't that great
isn't that wonderful these books happen
to be what was called the deluxe edition
of the collected works of shalom
aleichem show malaysia was one of the
most popular yiddish writers of all time
shalom alechem's works along with more
than 11 000 other titles are all
available online to download for free to
anyone it continues to amaze us and
inspire us that these books continue to
come to us from all over the world susan
bronson is the center's executive
director it does seem like aaron's done
a whole lot more than just collect a
whole bunch of books
oh yeah i mean if we had just collected
the books and put them in a dusty vault
and closed the door and say great we we
saved the books you know that would have
been nice and it would have been
important just to have rescued these
artifacts but
everything we've done in 42 years has
basically been to try to open those
books up
metaphorically speaking and literally
literally to a new generation what makes
a language beautiful
yiddish to me is a beautiful language
that includes yiddish center fellow
and tick-tocker cameron bernstein every
trend on the internet can connect to
yiddish and i having so much amazing
access to these books can just pull from
the vast collection of yiddish knowledge
and say well it's exactly like this meme
let me just like reformat it and share
what i love so much in an internet
language that other people can
understand
aaron lansky says he hopes a generation
from now the idea of this place is no
longer a big deal
that a long maligned once nearly
destroyed language
will never be
again
when people say to you
why are you doing this
what do you say i say culture matters
you know it matters in every way it
matters all over the world that
as human beings we tell stories and we
produce artifacts and we produce
literature and that really defines us to
a remarkable degree all those things
matter
and if you don't have them
you don't know who you are
from an idea
to what he's made all these now the
challenges remain only three percent of
the of the yiddish books so far have
been translated to english they're still
working on all that because so many
people don't know it you know my
grandmother was the last in our family
that spoke yiddish and my mom only
picked up words i know a few but it's
not a language that in our family we
have anymore it's proof of exactly how
it how it dies out yeah cameron though
the tick tocker i love her kids like him
and trying to pick it up and learn it
and that's the secret